is nope calves you cabs of tarantulas  fighting for them I don't fight for the  calves and Kevin of Durant small forward  to the Oklahoma Citadel well okay  technically I'm a free agent but I'm  gonna resign from on my year because the  gold cap goes up and I can get more  money  it doesn't matter that's not why I'm  here you could come fight for us excuse  me I was there when Steven Adams was  flagrantly fouled by a shadow with your  face you kicked him in the bollocks I  did  [Music]  in the name of house thunder champions  of the Northwest Division rightful kings  of the Western Conference for masonic  sub seattle and the first men i kevin of  durant former MVP sentence you to  justice you have any last words your  duty what'd you call me i said do your  duty